alex vellens decided he wanted to become
a boy when he was 12.
without that um help to transition then
i probably wouldn't be here today the
actual assessment process it basically
just felt the therapy they were just
like digging in and going why are you
trans why do you feel like that lots and
lots of assessments lots of
weird questionnaires there's no walking
in okay here's some drugs
alex came here the tavistock center for
treatment to help him transition
it's also where kira bell came for her
gender dysphoria treatments
at 16 her treatment began with puberty
blockers
kira later regretted the treatment and
has now de-transitioned
kira won legal action against the
tavistock and portman nhs foundation
trust these drugs seriously harm me in
more ways than one and they have harmed
many more particularly young girls and
women
this judgment is not political
it's about the protection of vulnerable
children
but that ruling has now been overturned
by the court of appeal kira says the
case has shown a light into the dark
corners of a medical scandal
paul jenkins chief executive of the
tavistock importment trust rejects
allegations that the treatment offered
by his clinic harms children it's a very
small
percentage of young people who go
through forward from our service to any
kind of physical intervention we are not
sending a whole load of people off to be
uh to be sterilized and we do explore
other ways in which uh young people's
distress and other things can be uh can
can be uh can be managed campaigners
against puberty blockers like stephanie
davis arai say they will continue
fighting
i don't believe that children certainly
under the age of 16
really understand what the implications
are for their adult lives of this
hormonal treatment some of which is
irreversible in serious ways in their
ruling the high court judges said that
treating children for gender dysphoria
is controversial and subject to intense
professional
and public debate
that debate
has just intensified
ashish joshi sky news